how did you end up with bunny actually
playing on uh john and yoko's double
fantasy album like how does that come
about i think that was jack douglas who
did our first record producer the
producer yeah he did aaron smith he did
all kinds of stuff you did our first
record why does jack call you was there
something john couldn't play or he
wanted a heavier sound because if you
listen to double fantasy now i mean it
sounds kind of loungy to me and yeah and
it's like it sounds like studio guys
which it was and yeah he wants a harder
edge and so so they call you in as a
hired gun in a sense and what song do
you perform uh losing you and moving on
what does he say to you he said while i
was playing uh losing you
[Music]
he said
oh play that go ahead play that a little
bit
he said god i wish i would have had he
said to bunny and jack he said i wish i
would have had him on cold turkey said
clapton choked up but did he say that
that's what he said to them but but that
is a great sound in other words john
couldn't come up with that sound himself
or play it himself it was like keith
richards like rob and xander like pete
townsend they can play great rhythm
stuff yeah besides you know the solos
like you know we're getting higher eddie
van halen you know but the thing that
you could do that john couldn't feel is
that is that sort of lead guitar
[Music]
and he
and when john heard you do that like he
gave you basically what he wanted to
play but did it sound anything like that
no it was
[Music]
that's what makes the [ __ ] song right
but john was smart enough to bring you
in we actually were inspired to record
it we have a recording of them
and i love that recording by the way
yeah yeah yeah yeah and after we
recorded and then stuff uh
we've talked about doing
an album with you know cheap trick being
john lennon's band oh
we would have done that then robin says
he pissed off he said they don't need to
say well no we want robin no robin too
like what rob what you could have been
on the album oh i would have been i'd
have forced my way in there somehow why
would that have felt like you were being
replaced as leads well you know that's
right
i think i think actually the combination
of your voices and everything really
kind of cool it would have been pretty
cool i wish i'd been there